dans cette petite église orthodoxe de la
région de kerkiff à une vingtaine de
kilomètres seulement de la frontière
russe le prêtre et les fidèles ont
choisi de célébrer la messe de Noël le
25 décembre au lieu du 7 janvier une
façon de marquer leur défiance vis-à-vis
de la Russie
[Musique]
avant nous prenons tout ce qu'on nous
imposait pour argent comptant
on ne réfléchissait pas mais maintenant
dans notre famille on ne parle plus que
le craignant et on éduque notre enfant
dans la culture ukrainienne pour ce qui
est des traditions et des fêtes
je ne veux rien avoir en commun avec
ceux qui bombardent notre pays massacre
nos enfants le Père rien a dit a passé
70 jours dans sa cave sous les
bombardements pendant l'occupation russe
ils nous ont apporté l'horreur la mort
et la ruine
je ne veux pas être avec un patriarche
et un clergé qui nous méprise et nous
souhaite la mort
nous arrachons au fer de la domination
impérialiste
maintenant que nous sommes libres nous
pouvons dire que nous sommes
indépendants de l'église de Moscou qui
nous dominaient et que nous a volé notre
identité
en ce matin de Noël si particulier pour
ses fidèles nombreux sont ceux qui
prient pour les membres de leur famille
victimes de la guerre des prières
collectives vont toutes à l'Ukraine et à
la victoire